dude come on look how natural that looks
look at that this is probably the best
phone for photography on the market
currently in the first half of 2023.
this is the xiaomi 13 Pro
collaboration with Leica this is the 12s
Ultra improved now I've been watching
some video reviews that have been out
there already covering the uh the
Chinese version which of course this is
the global launch and I had the 12s
Ultra we used it quite a bit we did some
videos here on the channel and the 12s
Ultra was a great I mean this is the
first collaboration between Leica and
xiaomi one inch sensor those vibrant
Leica colors all that stuff but when it
came to the ultra watt of the telephoto
things kind of fell apart because they
weren't as strong
this time with the 13 Pro all three
cameras are 50 megapixel on the back now
there's one that is a one inch sensor
it's a 23 millimeter F 1.9 but then for
the telephoto we have a 75 F2 then you
have an ultra wide as well which is also
50 megapixels
so when you look at the images there's
really not much of a discernible
difference in terms of the quality now
of course the sensors are different
sizes but with AI with the color science
everything that is put inside of this
xiaomi and Leica have done an amazing
job
on top of that
as I was just showing you the portrait
mode on this thing is nuts
this thing acts like and produces images
that you would not know came from a
smartphone the way that the Fallout hits
uh bokeh the depth of field
it is
I've never seen something this good out
of a smartphone and I've tried them all
all right let's talk display on this
thing you got a 6.73 inch OLED display
high resolution 120 hertz refresh rate
on this you've got 12 gigabytes of RAM
in the unit that we have 512 gigabytes
of storage as well so this is a packed
foam
4820 milliamp battery let me give you
pretty much all-day battery life
depending on how you use it but if you
use the camera quite a bit it's going to
drain and you're going to want to use
the camera quite a bit on this but you
do have fast charging wireless charging
as well and like other phones out there
that come from China there is a charger
in the Box what else 32 megapixel
facility camera on this now the selfie
camera is decent we'll show you some
images I mean it's pixel bidding the 32s
the 40s and all that kind of stuff when
it comes to the front facing camera
honestly a lot of it's marketing hype
but it is the rear cameras that are the
star of this show anyway let's walk
around Jackie let's take some photos
beautiful morning great light we got
blue skies it's a rarity here in
Singapore this time of year let's take
some Street photographs now the camera
you can go up to 70 times Zoom honestly
speaking
it's a little bit uh
I wouldn't use this image that looks
that doesn't look good
no he's not putting that on his Cinder
profile anyway he's on a date with
somebody else maybe he won't need Tinder
look let's be frank this 70 time 200
times 100 times zooms it's a gimme it's
fun if you want to like be a little bit
of a voyeur or use it as let's say
binoculars but I wouldn't use photos for
it right use what the camera has
naturally inside of it
okay once you get into this digital Zoom
like this it all looks like crap
forget the 70 times zero
just walk out closer and take a photo it
looks so much better now we're gonna go
to 50 megapixel mode here notice it all
three lenses 50 megapixel baby
look at the colors on that look at the
colors
that's with the main camera
Ultra wide
telephoto
and what's nice is
the xiaomi has now matched the colors to
all three of these cameras usually on a
lot of smartphones the main camera looks
great
when you go the ultra wide and the
telephoto huh this all three the color
science the colors all match
it's beautiful so we're gonna try video
on the front-facing camera here and
we're looking at the settings again only
1080 30 FPS unfortunately xiaomi has not
adopted 4K yet for the front-facing
camera but it does look pretty good and
you do actually have an f-stop here so
you can adjust the bokeh if you want to
do that
so I'm going to go to a f 2.5 try this
out right now and this is the
front-facing camera here on the xiaomi
13 Pro I will say that in terms of
dynamic range the sky is completely
blown out
so in terms of the metering it's a
little bit off but the image looks
pretty good it looks sharp we'll see how
the audio is right now so we're going to
try this without using any sort of a
depth of field mode on the front-facing
video camera
so now we're using the rear camera here
on the 13 Pro
and I turn off HDR because HDR is just a
little bit too aggressive on this but
again does a decent job we've got some
sun peeking through here how does that
handle the sun coming over my shoulder
how'd the colors look is this something
that you would definitely use for video
let me know all right that was 1080 now
we're going to 4K 24p
on the rear cameras and I like that they
have 24p on this because sometimes on
Android phones they actually just do 30
and 60. you have to use a pro mode to go
into 24 but in this camera app it's
there hopefully it looks better than the
1080 the 1080 was a little bit too much
the HDR was crazy so let's see how this
fares and plus we've got sun coming in
so we're really testing the camera how
it performs with backlight and lighting
situations how does it look like without
Dolby vision
which would you prefer love to hear from
you guys based on these two video
samples here again 4K 24p and I'm not
sure coming out of the camera no Dolby
Vision all right now we got ak24p
xiaomi is thinking Cinema 24p that's
what you want to shoot or 23.98 so send
them up at 24 is pretty much where you
want to go with this the colors are a
little bit more vibrant than some other
phones out there and this is of course
going to be a look you can't turn a
little bit you know tone that down a
little bit in post but I gotta say it
adds a little bit of character a little
bit of a look it's not as aggressive as
the 12s Ultra so to compare it to that
phone to this this is a much more toned
down but still has that uh Leica color
that vibrancy again it's just colored
science but you've seen that here on the
phone and the AK looks actually pretty
good I would definitely use this
a cool feature in this is we got
teleprompter mode this is interesting
because let's say you want to talk about
a product let's want to talk about these
pallets sometimes we can't remember
these things that's why we do multiple
takes when I do these videos but now
with teleprompter mode I can actually
talk about it and it's recording at the
same time
so people are gonna go wow you're so
eloquent with your words how do you make
it work
s looking for a reliable eco-friendly
solution for your shipping and storage
needs look no further than our high
quality wood palette choose from a
variety of sizes and styles to find your
perfect fit for your business and enjoy
competitive pricing and fast delivery
contact us today to order your premium
wood pallets
all done by chair gbt then sack here
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head
and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of format function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
oh yeah
that's what I'm talking about
have you seen a smartphone shoot like
this before
come on
75 F2
one of the most exciting features for me
personally is someone who loves
photography is the portrait mode in the
13 Pro because this unlocks
the Leica part of this camera system now
like has been working with xiaomi on the
entire thing but this is where you get
to play with the different lenses and
the different looks case in point
when we go into portrait mode you click
on this icon to the left you have black
and white swirly bouquet portrait and
soft focus but each of these represent a
different look any different focal
length that is very reminiscent of what
Leica offers in their lens lineup case
in point black and white is a 35 1.4
which is a sumalux shot black and white
because that is pretty much the de facto
Street photographer's lens the black and
white is gorgeous it is beautiful
unfortunately you can only use the Black
and Whites with a 35 1.4 a focal length
on this so if you want to do 75 or you
want to do some sort of Zoom or Ultra
wide you can't as of right now at least
from what I'm seeing here currently in
this setup when we go to the swirly
bouquet which is 50 millimeters which
represents the knock Deluxe now you
can't adjust the bouquet on each of
these they're sort of preset but it's
going to give you that knock Deluxe look
which is beautiful if you ever shot with
an octoluxe it's usually at 0.95 or F1
or F 1.2 and you're going to get a
beautiful depth of field but it's got a
character to it which is interesting
then we go into portrait mode which is a
75 F2 this is much more of a modern
rendering portrait lens I've shot a lot
of my images with this it looks great
how it just resolves the background the
depth of feel to the foreground it's
gorgeous it's awesome to see and then we
go into What's called the 90 millimeter
software which is going to represent the
Leica thumb bar lens now for those who
have never used this lens it's basically
like putting Vaseline on the front of
your front element of your lens and
shooting with it it is swirly nothing is
sharp it is as it's very character
driven it looks like a cheap lens but
for a lot of collectors out there they
search high and low for the thumb bar
because it offers something different
and something unique in case in point
here's a guy on the bike right here
and that's your end result with the 90
millimeter not everybody's gonna like it
it's not a hugely popular lens some
collectors love it but it's something
different
but it's actually really really cool
final thoughts on this phone I
absolutely love it as a photography tool
it's creative it's fun it produces
awesome images I love the like of
collaboration it's even more refined
here than in the 12s Ultra and you're
still getting that one inch sensor for
the main camera which is great but now
all three cameras are 50 megapixel in
terms of video it's okay I definitely
think that there probably are better
Android phones than other you know even
the iPhone it's probably better for
video as it stands right now but I think
this camera strength is in its
photography so if you're someone who
likes to take more photos than videos I
definitely recommend this you're still
getting a good video out of this don't
get me wrong and I'm sure with firmware
updates they will improve as time goes
on because we're still have this we
still have this in advance it's kind of
a pre-release version
but as it stands right now to me
optically photography
this is
probably the best camera system on a
smartphone for the first half of 2023
for photos
you're gonna love this anyway those are
my thoughts if you like this video
subscribe to the channel hit that like
button and check out more of our reviews
right here
she wants to as well
foreign